♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how Cloud SQL
can help you save time
in developing your next great app.
Cloud SQL is a fully-managed
relational database service
from MySQL, Postgre,
or SQL Server on Google Cloud.
It lets you hand off
mundane, time-consuming tasks,
like patches, updates,
backups, and replicas,
so you can focus on building your app!
Cloud SQL integrates
with BigQuery for analytics
or connects as a backend
to your App Engine, Compute Engine,
or Kubernetes apps.
Setting up Cloud SQL
is quick and seamless.
In a snap, you can create
in an instant with the Cloud console
by choosing the type
of database version and location
or use the gcloud command line.
Then you're ready to upload your data
and connect your applications.
To go further, set up automatic backups,
replication, and failover,
so you can create a highly-available
database for critical applications.
You get full encryption
at rest and in transit,
keeping your private data
safe and compliant.
External connections can be encrypted
using SSL or Cloud SQL proxy.
Being a relational database,
Cloud SQL is great for OLTP
where frequent queries
and fast response time are needed.
You can use it to manage everything
from a single WordPress blog
to a global aggregation
of wheat crops and rainfall.
Next time you're looking
for a quick relational database solution,
take a minute to try out Cloud SQL.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/sql.